[Musique]
on a eu une grande conférence autour de
l'avenir de l'opéra à new york
il y avait beaucoup d'air
des gens qui quittaient les dirigeants
de grandmaison de l'opra qui parlaient
de leur budget de souscription vendus et
aucun français en piste au milieu de
tous ces gens
une jeune petit homme se mettre à parler
en anglais avec une action de jeunes ne
prenait pas de bouger des souscriptions
par les doigts
c'est étonnant dans cette compagnie il
parlait incarne qui était pratique qui
était vraiment sophistiqué ça il faut
dire vraiment quelqu'un qui propose pour
qui c'était pas les clichés ce délai les
vrais français et il ne l'est pas il
n'hésite pas emprunter les quelqu'un
c'était les pensées très personnel qui
offrit à ce public bizarre pour le site
centenaire du met et et puis dans son
discours trois quatre fois ils disent
aimer dons pour ça je suis absolument
d'accord avec le jeune homme de se mater
peter service quand il a dit monsieur
vous voulez bien
voilà voilà
c'est une question piège de se vanter je
sais que vous avez vous avez une
télévision et messieurs bonsoir
événement musical ce soit vous le savez
va se dérouler à la fois au théâtre
royal de la monnaie et sur votre petit
écran puisque nous allons suivre en
direct d'unités rain don carlo 2
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je savais que je devais prendre cette
maison avec une force inébranlable que
je devais venir faire très vite prendre
des décisions ne pas attendre le conseil
d'administration négocier tout de suite
avec quelques jours en privé des
syndicats pour arriver si j'aurai fait
tout cela selon les lois administrative
j'aurais jamais pu obtenir cela donc je
fais vraiment fait la tactique d'aller
très vite dans un pays que l'on
connaissait rien qu'ils étaient surpris
tout le monde s'était déjà fait un
moment que les gens ne s'était pas
encore rendu compte que cet effet je
crois que si vous prenez la brochure il
ya en plus dans la recherche d'une belle
photo avec un sous titre qui dit élevage
de poussière c'est à dire si nous
réussissent dans à réaliser notre
réflexion on peut éliminer la poussière
qui est dessus l'opéra mais si on ne
réussit pas on cultive la poussière
naples et la maison si je peux dire le
1er juillet le 2 juillet sont arrivés
des grands camions d aide avec des
aspirateurs pour enlever la poussière de
la scène
il n'y avait rien n'y avait pas des
projecteurs la chimie on ne savait pas
ce que c'était
donc on a tout un stade on a acheté tout
les appareils électriques on avait
besoin on a laissé faire souvent des
décors dans le meilleur ateliers de
d'italie parce qu'on avait nous même pas
beaucoup d'autres causes j'ai pour ma
part une production de clément et titus
invité les meilleurs peintres
d'allemagne pour parler des corps de
hermann où j'ai acheté pour tous les
musiciens de nouveaux instruments de la
meilleure louis ii trèbes au violon j'ai
reçu un emprunt ce la mise en scène
nettement tout de suite je savais que je
vais mettre sur les meilleurs met en
scène d'europe il ya eu beaucoup de
commentaires sur la gestion et des
commentaires qu'il n'était pas toujours
signé et anonyme
et si on m a parlé de gestion les
syndicats je les ai convaincus en leur
promettant d'augmenter le nombre de
places salmonelles dont il y avait un
personnel environ 2 340 quand je suis
arrivé et je quitte avec 500 dont j'ai
créé quand même 160 nouvelles places
mais sous condition qu'ils avaient une
paix sociale pendant trois ans et si on
veut attaquer le plan du on dit toujours
que ça coûte cher on dit voilà le décor
coûte cher alors on ne sait jamais que
le décor ne représentent qu'eux mêmes
que 5 % du budget global
il ya tellement d'autres choses dans la
vie chère très chère à l'opéra c'est
d'ailleurs qu'on ne peut pas faire un
opéra sans avoir un personnel énorme
chaque spectacle d'opéra demande pour la
réalisation le soir même 200 personnes
et puis encore 280 à la préparation
c'est donc d'une usine de moyens ordre
et donc si on a quatre sens à la vie ça
coûte cher
[Musique]
j'ai plus à l'assemblée dans cette
maison des hommes importants dans le
monde industriel et financier sans le
soutien de ces gens que j'ai convaincu
pour le modèle de bras que je fais le
gouvernement n'aurait jamais suivi au
moment que j'ai demandé plus d'argent
pour ses théâtres
whissell est une ville de province mais
avec quelques devoirs européenne et elle
veut être une capitale de l'europe ce
n'est pas du tout malheureusement mais
peut-être avec lequel je pourrais en
faire une capitale 0 maintenant quand
j'ai dit ça beaucoup de gens ont pensé
que cela veut dire que je vais faire un
théâtre de prestige ce n'est pas du tout
ça une capitale n'est pas nécessairement
le prestige les terres de province font
souvent le prestige
non parce qu'ils affichent des grands
vedette 10 il vient du metropolitan
capitale ça veut dire quelque chose
d'autre capitale avait dit je crois
c'est un lieu de rencontre sur un plan
national et quand bruxelles veut être
une capitale de l'europe ça veut dire
qu'elle doit avoir à dire quelque chose
dans l'europe d'aujourd'hui
et en ce moment il y très pur jus et
quand je vois l'évolution des chiffres
de la monnaie je suis vraiment inquiet
parce que je me dis que l'on risque si
on continue dans cette voie de
compromettre cet acquis extraordinaire
les dépenses qu'ils étaient deux en 1981
de 418 millions sont passés à un
milliard 154 millions dans les trois
dernières années monsieur mortier il y a
eu une majoration des dépenses de 40 3%
alors que les recettes stagnent et ce
qui a fait que le déficit n'est ce pas
est passé de 87 millions mais ce sont
les chiffres que je retrouve dans vos
budget vous vous faites des signe de
dénégation mais je prends vos comptes au
budget faux chiffres
le prix des places à la monnaie y aussi
la place la plus chère je prends en
période normale est de 16 cents francs
la place de la moins chère et 250 francs
et si on fait une moyenne compte tenu du
nombre de spectateurs et sur base de la
recette qui a été engrangé et donc du
prix des places qui a été payé et bien
dire est qu'en moyenne les spectateurs
payent 600 francs et bien savez vous ce
que représente une subvention de 545
millions
ça signifie que pour chaque spectateur
l'état verse un montant qui est d'au
moins 5 à 6000 francs
[Musique]
le grand réveil a eu lieu comme vous
savez après deux ans quand j'ai présenté
la note de 100 millions de francs belges
de déficit mais entre temps il était
tellement content de ce qui s'était
passé que on a pu convaincre des gens
pour rhdp cela vous y en avait une
subvention mais abominable quand je suis
arrivé il y avait je dois dire 50
millions de francs français de
subventions ce kit est rien du tout
[Musique]
sensible et quand j'en aurai pas mettre
leur reste sur un niveau technique très
bien et j'avais besoin d'une star comme
john plichart pour attirer des bons
musiciens dans ce thème quoi là on veut
entend distinctement gère des plus
profonds sur les cinquante musiciens qui
jouaient à bruxelles il y en avait 32
ans j'ai fixé j'ai tout de suite invité
avec john pritchard à dire qu'ils
étaient super league invité dans un très
bon appartement le représentant syndical
de leurs castres à paris un dîner
superbe lundi on doit changer leurs
questions doit faire des auditions
donc tout le monde qui n'étaient pas
dans leur caisse plus que deux ans je
veux les écouter
je dois dire aussi qu'on était très
démocrate en tout les auditions dans la
sphère des milliers pour choeur et
orchestre que j'ai à chaque fois les
membres du choeur et doivent qu'est-ce
qui était présent avec nous avec le
matin on venait anti-abus scènes
additionnelles jusqu'au dernier on veut
porter à paris parfois sans avoir à
engager personnes c'était vraiment
détendue que je peux avoir des meilleurs
mettre en scène pour faire mozart il ya
une jeune génération de chanteurs qui
est mozart et j'avais deux chefs
d'orchestre mais mozart donc c'est en
travaillant ainsi que j'ai senti que
mozart qui viendrait le centre
[Musique]
au moment que j'arrivais à bruxelles je
mettais je m'étais battu avec pas mal
d'argent jamais même tout de suite exclu
certains agence pour négocier la monnaie
d'une part c'est de mon habitude de
négocier tout de suite directement avec
les chanteurs et après de fait les
contrats avec les agents bien
[Musique]
c'est un de mes grands plaisirs non pas
de prendre un chanteur dans un groupe
qui a déjà chanté mais de convaincre un
chanteur de chanter nouvelle rue
je crois que c'est un talent que j'ai je
veux pas dire des choses plus de moi
mais je crois vraiment que j'ai amené
pour sentir une rolls pour un certain
chanteur aussi bien du point de vue de
personnages que de chance de chanter et
parfois je me suis trompé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
quand je me réveille le matin c'est
drôle les meilleurs jeux ses idées j'ai
souvent sous la douche et parfois j'ai
une une rôle dans ma tête
est ce que j'ai mal à la plus belle
chose que je fais au bureau c'est de
voir le téléphone de surprendre le
chanteur et de dire je voulais faire ça
avec vous les jeunes chanteurs on les
envoie par tous dans des rôles souvent
qu'ils sont pas les leurs dès qu'un
ténor 1 un timbre automatique doit
chanter du wagner et finalement une
serait qu'un bon t91 matic mozartien
[Musique]
j'ai jamais beaucoup pensé à la claire
parce que je suis pas un très grand bac
gallia et finalement j'ai fait tous les
puristes vague de souffle cameron je
crois avec tous les gens que je
travaille se sont en même temps des amis
je pourrais pas travailler avec des gens
que je connais pas berne que par exemple
que je connaissais pas au moment que je
les contacter pour faire le ring est
devenu un ami pendant le travail parce
que on a tellement discuter j'aime
pendant que jean travail de les inviter
en week end d'aller me promener avec de
discuter sur d'autres choses aussi du
dîner avec eux le soir je vais parfois
dans les ardennes où j'ai mon hôtel puis
je plan des chambres et puis je discute
avec eux j'aime à chaque fois et il je
crois pas que je peux trouver avec des
metteurs en scène avec lesquels je me
sens pas en relation amicale dehors
c'est la même chose pour la chaîne
turque est
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est ce que les gens adorent dans le
ring de richard wagner
ce n'est pas l'annoncé de la mort par
exemple à ziigmund mais le grand marche
funèbre qui fait beaucoup de bruit
donc on sent quand on leur demande
pourquoi ils aiment au départ le tourner
à l'opéra on sent que ce sont les mêmes
phénomènes hiller la porte aussi bien le
disco le laser le drague ccsa l'opéra
donc on ne doit pas se faire des
illusions sur le succès actuel
vous allez la monnaie vous êtes en train
de travailler sur la flûte enchantée ce
sera la première production de la flûte
enchantée à la monnaie sous votre
direction j'avais dire sur votre rêve
non non et cet après midi vous m'avez
demandé de faire entendre ce soir une
phrase musicale très particulière de la
flûte enchantée et bien je crois que la
flûte enchantée est vraiment une pièce
qui dit tout sur la vie la vie de
l'homme
séduit il démontre mozart la fin de sa
vie c'est qu' il n'y a pas de vide qui
existe sans épreuve et il démontre que
la seul moyen pour lui pour lui mozart
ça la musique
[Musique]
cet autre côté absolument intuitive de
petite enfance place fait les yeux pour
ça avec une grande amour passion pour
une vie imaginaire you taux plein donc
c'est pour ça que j'ai adoré les utopies
créée par karl instruments sur scène les
absolument séduit par cet univers où
tout les techniques marche d'une façon
parfaite et tous les animaux sont en
place elles mènent étaient devenus un
peu membres de la maison un certain
moment et c'est lui qui est venu avec
l'idée de la finta giardiniera j'avoue
que à ce moment là je n'avais jamais
écouté la pièce il y avait qu à
l'enregistrement celui d'il ya pas tiger
et après un acte j'ai déjà mis le disque
de côté je trouvais ça très ennuyeux si
l'un cambrin a plus la partition qui ne
concerne lui même pas non plus et au
départ n'était pas tout à fait convaincu
7 en réétudiant l'écran semble surtout
la finale du premier acte et du deuxième
j'ai dit non c'est une pièce qui a déjà
tout s qui sera développée après dans
les nasses et figaro
[Musique]
on a pris une période dans nos vacances
pendant pendant l'été je crois oui un
italien ensemble dans un à tête très
tranquille très agréable dans la tosca
mme haman adji haman jack layton sylvain
tremblay et moi on a passé une semaine
ensemble sur la finta giardiniera quand
je dis des vacances avaient quand même
dire qu'on commençait chaque matin aux
heures d hermann même à dormir un peu
plus longuement que moi on va commencer
on n'a pas mangé le midi on se tait
jusqu'à soir 6 avec du thé entre temps
mais c'était quand même chaque jour 6 à
r par air mot par mot qu'on a analysées
[Musique]
ce qui est maintenant très beau c'est
que tout cela s'est exprimé dans la mise
en scène le décor avec les arbres la
grande table qui sont dans une
magnifique ligne qui se décompose
on peut les trouver dans le paysage
flamand on peut les trouver dans le
paysage de ce calme et c'est là que
hermann a réduit et je suis l'idée de la
nature en ordre et rentrent et sortent
comme les sentiments amoureux
[Musique]
et
c'est aussi en travaillant dans cet
hôtel où on entendait tous les bruits
des animaux les cloches
il vient tous ses bruitages si je peux
dire vous l'a retrouvé dans la mise en
scène
parce que on sentait justement quand tu
es là que c'était une pièce qui pouvait
se jouer au lieu où on était soir quand
aller se promener on a tous je sens
qu'il y avait un petit bras que c'était
ce bois là où devait se jouer la finale
[Musique]
on a répété pour la fildak jardinières
et pendant deux mois
3 les pétitions pajot donc neuf heures
par jour pendant deux mois avec un jour
de repos par semaine auxquelles sylvain
comblant étaient présents pendant deux
mois sans interruption et auquel tous
les chanteurs étaient présents
[Musique]
m
l'année
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est presque impossible à travailler
comme ça aux états unis c'est très très
cher et c'est n'est qu'aujourd'hui
douze mois plus tard que la présentation
s'est faite de celui qui doit devenir le
successeur de déjà le chorégraphe
américain mark morris ici c'est c'est
tout bref je vais simplement dire que je
trouve que la presse belge a été très
sévère envers marc morize peut-être avec
raison de temps en temps mais comme
directeur de ce théâtre vous dit aussi
comprendre que je ne peux pas laisser
changer ma politique par une opinion de
place un prêt c'est venu un soir le
public est venu tous les soirs les
réactions étaient très partagés entre je
dirais les bravos et les huées mais je
pense que ce n'est pas mauvais comme
réaction au moins ça ne laisse pas les
gens indifférents
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
roy une soutien comme ça qu'on est un
artiste parce que comme artiste on est
toujours jusqu'au bout du panic est
toujours mise en question
on est toujours en train de s'en doutait
on est toujours en train de expérimentés
et c c'est souvent il ya des risques
ça prend du courage sa demande ça exige
une concentration et aux synergies très
très très fort et on est très très très
tôt épuisé et donc il faut avoir un
producteur qui comprend ça et qui
comprend comment en vraiment peu de
données un soutien qui va vraiment
améliorer le travail et je veux reçues
liées reçu les lignes et ça se dit bon a
souligné que enfin c'est pas mozart
solar c'est paradoxal mais le but de
l'opra c'est qu'on travaille avec
beaucoup de gens et les choses qui se
passe c'est quelque chose qui se passe
entre les gens vous avez le crepac c'est
un club
ces chanteurs par par exemple jef k o à
11 heures pendant le soir
créé par à 9,9 r ils sont tous
différents avec tous les we say say say
11 c'est incroyable et en plus un doigt
est je crois et aux petits as les offres
d'emploi et enfin sur un chef de
simplement les voir travailler c'est
vraiment comme frères enjoy
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
o o
[Musique]
oh
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
m
[Musique]
oh
ça
[Musique]
oh
tél
most important thing we can build aux
munichois de rire seront évoqués milioni
di additionnels selon as bad teamsite
pop de funk soul / you can have ever in
your browser
in spain un ring à cette folie figure au
patronat l'abolition un ministère just
maybe ailleurs a few days of may be for
five ok end à la couronne speech race
deeside au bord de cette dalle de masse
biocontact between assistante à la
technique du recteur
tout est dit elle every thing you need
faudra céder leurs parts of à natal you
should make very good riz à soro est
fantastique inouïe l'udaf cardy next
next in de plaine un élève de gaulle
dimanche 27 à 6 mi-temps
pour moi il était toujours facile roma
c'est sa fille et je veux dire une chose
ce qu elle l a donné tellement de joie
parce que personne n'oubliera sourire
dans les couloirs de la monnaie alors
dès que mme adam malysz vestas
[Applaudissements]
ce qui est fantastique que les gens
baissent comme elle tous ensemble
légumes les en choeur les femmes que les
machinistes
[Musique]
ce qui m'amuse le plus c'est l'amitié et
je crois que j'ai senti beaucoup de gens
qui connaissaient pas et elle a ce soir
et que ça veut dire
il ya quelque chose qui a été créée d'un
sourd il ya plus fort de jo
je parle aujourd'hui définitivement pour
faire mon plein du festival en donnant
du donc pendant l'été 92 et que vous
vivez avec un mozart bien sûr dans la
ville de mozart avec la clémence et
quitus pour la jauge et van damme bien
sûr dans la première saison avec le
saint-françois d'assise de messiaen en
ville a indiqué qu'il pensait à rolle
position sauce borg
je me disais pourquoi vraiment pas quoi
est ce qu'on a vraiment besoin de ça
c'est pas simplement une une mal à la
tête
c'est c'est une espèce de suicide c'est
quoi c'est c'est parce qu'ils
s'intéressent dont le poouvoir culture
que là je me demandais absolument je
crois que je regarde pense qu'il a une
vraie mission pour l'europe de l'impôt
missionnaire
les gens qui sont qui te parle d'un
déficit que je laisserais pour mon
successeur
sur une mauvaise foi parce que le
positif le bilan positif est tellement
énorme que tout est d'ailleurs je
n'accepterai pas que je réagirais tout
de suite la chose de plus important pour
moi c'est que ça ce bourg était le
symbole
actuellement la commercialisation d'un
d'utilisation dollar
et j'avais envie de briser cela peut
être que moi je sais qu'on peut éviter
ça je ne sais pas mais si on peut
changer quelque chose
assas booth a pu avoir de l'effet de
tout
yves calvi l'europe il n'y a aucun
artiste musicale au monde entier qui ne
veut pas chanter ou dirigés au mettre en
scène à salzbourg
il y a dans cette ville et dans ce
théâtre il est meilleur
jean par exemple les peintres qui sont
contents de faire ici
la peinture pour hermann à bruxelles je
devais le six seven & i sinon ils sont
là parce qu'ils adorent ce festival ils
savent que c'est quelque chose
d'extraordinaire mais dont bourg et déjà
ceux qui connaissaient la clémence de
titus à bruxelles simpliste et sa maman
un saule blanc
ici c'est un sol qui a déjà des éléments
roma qui se passait beaucoup plus
sophistiqué et en même temps dans les
costumes c'est donc le jeton mandat pour
le connaissez partout un peu à marana
plumes
je veux prouver avec le premier mauzac
chanson avec amman ému ici que cette
pièce est vraiment extraordinaire
et ce qui était très intéressant de
savoir que c'était une cuisse de mozart
qui normalement se font jamais très bien
à salzbourg
les grands hits c'est giovanni les
menaces de figaro cosi fan tutte la
clémence de titus cette année ci est
complètement sainte anne
tu
le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
24 ans est enfin mise au delà des normes
un petit entraînement normal car cette
année
kim est notre défense dès maintenant on
veut tous bords du made in white party
c'est la grille mais l'art mois et demi
avant les total et au bataclan nature
destin de jouer pleinement et des
lettres anonymes et claude
deux loups et niko formule d'un homme ce
showmatch à demande qui est en train de
tâter du 6th et mig-29 est lors du all
it in what she wants to bring the light
et avant de football
yves jégo et la dette cds light
peut-être is not for youth for you to i
want your day one iq dans le parisien ce
dernier
il ya une atmosphère un peu comprenez
d'assises et lapierre a en elle même
en plus si les cloches sonnent dans sas
bourse étant il ya sept 7 explique mais
il ya un beau coup on a une force
extraordinaire avec un blanc place pour
120 musiciens acétique et dimitri
mitropoulos a affiché sa famille electro
et c'est un but justement où le saint
françois d'assise qui est un opéra cinq
grandes pièces religieuses pu prendre
une dimension qu'on ne peut lui jamais
donné dans à une salle d'opéra ge pas
retenu avec une magie un peu spécial
qu'on ressent peut-être aujourd'hui une
jeune et un peu plus vu nous pouvons
fermer le toit on s installer maintenant
une éclairage comme sur les terrains de
football donc on peut éclairer de telle
façon que ça donne encore l'impression
d'être une journée plein soleil
non
[Musique]
je ne peux que maîtriser une cinquante
qu'il voit la dimension vraiment et la
bob c'est d'ailleurs cette compétition
pour laquelle n'a pas une traduction
française et elle est très simple parce
que ce n'est qu'en la faisant qu'on peut
voir si le dimensions sont juste là
personne ne me croit mais c'est certain
qu'en quittant la monnaie je tournerai
plus jamais une institution de terrain
et parce que je sens que tout ce que
j'avais exprimé dans l'opéra
actuellement je crois que je les fais ça
ce bull pour moi c'était important de
entrer dans un type d'organisation où je
programme aussi du théâtre et du concert
et ce qui a étonné beaucoup de gens et
que pour mai était absolument logique
que pour le théâtre j'ai pris une
personnalité qui est beaucoup plus forte
que moi c'est péter stein donc quelqu'un
qui est plus fort et dont je sais qu'il
va porter pour moi en même temps pas une
concurrence mais qui m'oblige à
réfléchir encore plus forte si seul
opéra pour tenir la balance avec les
théâtres palais de temps entre la tour
complètement et ans a ses raisons mais
ces raisons sont bizarres sont
absolument intuitive et ses formes un
dentiste presque vraiment et ça je
trouve très sympathique
même si nous sommes pas d'accord je vous
trouve très sympa
c'est pour simplement téléphoner sur une
mise en scène de coffreur ça s'est
retourné habiter mort parce que si j'ai
simplement introduit la valise de la
taceq plus de la tâche etc et c'est le
smoking cessenonais gérard mortier
montreuil amoureux de mozart bien avant
moi encore ce qu'il a quelques années de
plus que moi
mais l'idée que les opéras jeunesse le
mozart avait un contenu théâtrale et
psychologique extrêmement fondamental et
n'avait pas vraiment réfléchi et
lorsqu'on a commencé ce qu'on va
commencer à travailler sur les opéras de
jeunesse de mozart
on a eu de très très longues
conversations sur le récitatif entre sa
pointe est très très précis on sait bien
que le récitatif s'il n'est pas envisagé
de façon très très très profonde
peut-être effectivement terriblement
ennuyeux et je crois que la meilleure
chose pour ouvrir cette conférence de
presse c'est de vous lire
quelques idées de hofmannsthal et de
ceux qui ont créé le festival
de quoi s'agit-il en somme opéra drane
ou festival de musique la question
réponse est opéra et ran simultanément
car ces deux genres dans leur conception
la plus élevée ne peuvent pas être
séparés les deux cautions suivante sont
très intéressants pour notre époque
voulez vous jouer pour les classes
supérieures
instruite ou pour les masses populaires
réponse ceux qui conçoivent en leur âme
la signification du terme peuple
n'admette rond point cette distinction
question suivante est en peuvent plus
étonnantes mozart et rococo le public
demande du nouveau les temps ont bien
changé
[Musique]
on
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oh
il
et
[Musique]
oh
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]